There we go. All right, welcome everybody. It is the 19th of September. We've been doing these Zoom calls for well over a year now.
And if you're new to all of this, please look back on the Facebook page. We have indexed them. I need to update the index. It was one month ago that I did that.
And see you can look on that Word document index sheet and see which ones you want to listen to so that we're not just repeating these over and over, even though I don't mind answering the questions again.
If we did answer them multiple times in the past, I would ask that you would look at those post those past Zoom calls. That's the whole purpose of them.
So questions are good. They're good because we can get answers. But sometimes I don't have the answer. So understand I will always be honest with you.
When you guys ask me questions, I don't know the answer. I could say I don't know the answer. It might be a question that I may want to look up and figure out the answer because that's how I learned and I've done that my whole all my 30 years of practice is I've learned from my patients.
And I mean things that they've taught me and also questions that they've brought me that sparked me to find out what that answer was. So I see that as a challenge. I see that as my purpose. But also I am not your Google. So I'm not here just to answer every question that you have. So just remember that.
And certainly I just don't know everything. I'm just not that smart of a guy. So bear with me with all of that. So we're going to jump on to some questions that I had come in.
One was a question, particularly pertaining to me, but we could pertain to other people as well. How can someone get cancer if they've been using the right for years and the question came out of email, how could you get cancer if you haven't been using the right for all these years.
I really struggle with that.
But we need to understand some things. Okay, so to answer that question, there's a multitude of facets to this. So number one, the right machine is frequency dependent.
So, for instance, in my case, my wife had melodoma. We were running melodoma programs for a number of years. And my cancer is not melodoma. Melodoma as a skin cancer, very different than my cancer.
So I wasn't running the right programs specifically for my cancer, even remotely. So when I say frequency dependent, it means that you only get the benefit from the right, depending on what frequencies you're ready.
You could say, well, how come I got the flu? I've been using the right all this time. Well, if you're running cold and flu and viral and bacteria programs, you're not killing any cold and flu and virus and bacteria.
If you're running lime programs and you got influenza bug, you have been running influenza bug. If you're running cancer programs and you got some other disease, it's frequency dependent. So it's dependent upon the frequencies that you're using.
That's what's going to be the thing that's going to be hit. So if you're not running the right frequencies, then you're not going to help yourself in that thing that you're trying to prevent or trying to cure.
Number two, understand the right is limited by distance. If the right is, you know, you know, farther away from you, you're going to get less benefit. And I've said that the right could be eight feet away from you, and you're going to get some benefit. But it's going to be very little comparative. The right was you were stuggling with the ball.
So there's actually physics formula every 12 inches or 10 centimeters. I don't know what the calculation is. Again, I think it's every 12 inches. You move something away from you. You have the benefit of the frequency.
So if the ball is five feet away from you, you're going to get a whole lot less benefit from the frequency that if it's next to you. So it is limited by distance as well.
And then three have to understand the right is not a magic one. It is not a policy for every disease. And to think that if I have a cold virus and I'm going to run a cold program and my cold is going to just go away.
You are delusional. It is not going to happen that way. It can. But to think that anything, whether it's a vitamin, oh, I have a cold. So I'm going to take vitamin C and my cold goes away. I think that's going to happen every time that you take vitamin C or garlic or a combination or the right is you're not being realistic.
It's really important to keep that in balance. The right of the sheet is a wonderful tool.
But it is a tool. Tools have to be used correctly. And tools are just that they aren't, you know, I have a chisel. It doesn't mean I'm going to be able to sculpt Michael Angelo out of a block of clay.
Or sculpt a David out of block of stone. It is, it's going to be it's how that tool is used is imported.
And it's simply a tool. So it's whoever's using that tool is going to make a big difference too.
Whoever placed the thought in anybody's mind that the right machine is any guarantee of a cure or prevention of any disease was not me.
So I am never stated that the right is any sort of cure all for anything and you know that.
So don't get tricked into thinking that it don't think that that if I'm using the right for my cancer now, my cancer is is going to go away.
There's so many other factors that are involved with this that you're not being realistic.
So make sure you take, you know, I am an optimist. Maybe, maybe some people would say I'm a pessimist. I, I think, honestly, I'm a realist. We just have to be realistic about things and keep things in perspective.
We don't want to have unrealistic expectations of anything that we do with life. I think that could lead to disappointments.
And when we have unrealistic expectations of something like we think that the right is going to cure our cancer now that I'm using the right. I would, I would be fine. I'm going to be cured.
And what would say, well, how can you say that, Dr. Cutters, you're taking away hope from somebody. I'm not trying to just keep keep it real.
If we have such unrealistic expectations on the sheet like the right for sheet or environment see therapy or in chemotherapy or in my oncologist or because I'm going to the best doctors at Mayo, that's really from
the truth of that, that's idolatry. And that is not, that's not have a place in our life. It certainly doesn't have a place in our clinic. And I'm certainly not going to advocate it. And if that's what you're going to stick to, then I think you're going to have some unfortunate come along with that.
There exists also a myriad of causes of considerations to any disease. So even if even if I was running the right for five years prior to my diagnosis of cancer and I, and I was running the exact right frequency all those five years prior to my diagnosis of cancer.
I mean, I'm not going to get that cancer. I hear this all the time from people, quite frequently, at least, that how could I have gotten cancer. I have been eating right, I've been eating organic for 10 years. I've never smoked, I've never drank, I've never done anything bad. How can I get cancer.
And that's, that's a struggle that people have. And I think it's a fair question to ask. But then the my question back to you is, how do you think that you that you have lived all these years and not gotten the serious disease or not gotten cancer.
It falls back to that not process that we feel like something is owed to us that we have a right to health that be healthy because of the wonderful things that we've done.
Yes, I think that we need to make steps to do wonderful things like eat correctly and not drinking and excess and, and taking care of our health and, and stayed away from EMFs and, and trying to live a good healthy life.
But there's no guarantees that that you're going to live to 120 years old.
There's no guarantees that you're still not going to deal with a serious disease like cancer. There's too many causal considerations to every disease.
There's too many things, even if you're living a perfectly clean lifestyle, you're still exposed to pesticides and chemicals and chemtrails.
And I tell people, hey, your, your, your shirt that you're wearing right now is not dyed with raspberries. It's dyed with chemicals. You're exposed to chemicals everywhere.
You're walking on carpeting that is off-gassing chemicals from your wall that are off-gassing pollutants in the air everywhere.
You're breathing in things exposed to things through your skin exposed to things through the environment. You cannot get away from it.
And even if you could, they're still in even the natural realm, a myriad of things that could cause disease.
So to think that you can completely prevent every disease by even doing everything that you know to do, to be that is right and good is, is, is, is ridiculous. It's just, it just is.
So you have to keep that balance. And then, and then lastly, we have to understand, do we not serve a sovereign God?
Even if I did everything right that's known to man that may be future known to man 200 years from now, we still serve a sovereign God.
And if he chooses to allow me to get cancer for some reason to bring him glory.
And if I am, I'm arguing with the God who created me, besides the fact that I believe that, who will I go to sex? I've lived 55 years without cancer. Praise God.
What, what, what a blessing that has been.
Do I think I have the right to not get sick? Do I have the right to not have financial concerns? Do I have the right to not have family problems?
Do I have the right to not go through crises in my life? We, we've become such a narcissistic society in America, because we live in relative peace and prosperity, that we, these things, we don't think that are, are somehow inherent rights that we have.
Whereas, really, if we put life and perspective even on earth today, the majority of people are living on, you know, 30 dollars a day in this world.
And we are, are 30 dollars a week in this world, and we are living in the top one half of one percent of the human race.
We talk about what's really fair. We are living in a very unfair world, and we are living in the, in the advantage of the real unfair world.
And we really want to put things back in perspective and everything we do. So, even though I understand this may have been a very honest question, how could someone get cancer if you've been using the right for years.
We don't want to be too, you know, so to agree with my answer, we have to, we have to be careful and hedge ourselves against the narcissistic thoughts that we have a right to something because we're doing the right things.
We are called to do the right things, but just because the outcome isn't what we selfishly want, doesn't mean it's not the right outcome.
And that's, that's sometimes a hard pill to swallow when, when, when I'm, when I'm a selfish person, which who I am, so I have to get over that. And that's one of the lessons in life.
The question, could someone please talk about the hormones, adaptogens, biological hormones and dealing with hormones.
And sure, I'll gladly talk about that.
So here's a picture of your endocrine system, endocrine is our glands that's agreed into the bloodstream and have an effect on distant organs.
And you have all these different glands in your body that do different things you put to a Terry glad that sits up on your brain, communicates to mainly your adrenals, your testes in bed, your ovaries and females affect your placenta and affect your thyroid gland.
And those are your main endocrine system glands that we talk about when someone says their hormones are on a balance.
So when we're talking about a woman feeling like her hormones on a balance and deciding whether to use a bioidentical hormone or not, we're really talking about your hormones of estrogen and progesterone primarily.
So obviously, when the person has low thyroid, they're on scintoroid or an equivalent of that.
And we often hear in functional medicine terms of people with low adredals, under stress, cortisol issues, norepinephrine, epinephrine issues with their adredal glands and needing some adrenal support, especially with their under stress.
Now, there's several different ways to deal with it and from a natural perspective, there are bioidentical hormones.
And that's really one of my degrees is in with bioidentical hormones, though I've never used bioidentical hormones in my practice.
And I have some reasons for not using it.
Any issue with someone choosing to use bioidentical hormones, except when you go down into the field of helping people with cancer, you can't use bioidentical hormones, it really shouldn't be using bioidentical hormones in my opinion.
Even if you don't have a hormone-driven cancer, so the other hormone-driven cancers, even if you're not ER or PR or HER2 positive, with breast cancer or ovarian cancer or uterine cancer, I still would not suggest using bioidentical hormones because we just don't know how that affects the cancer.
And if it's not showing on a lab test to be progesterator estrogen positive, so I would still say no to bioidenticals.
But what do you do if you have cancer and you're in a relatively stable place with your cancer, but you have all these hormone fluctuations.
Okay, so let's get into that.
So then you talk about adaptogenic herbs. So what are the different herbs to help balance hormone function?
There's a group of herbs called adaptogenic herbs, and adaptogenic herbs are called that because they tend to balance whether your hormones are a little bit high because your hyper stress.
Let's talk about your adrenals as an example. So if my adrenals are relatively in a hyper state because I'm in an acute stressful situation, that can cause harm and disruption and symptoms and unpleasantness, and taking adaptogens can help calm those down.
So adaptogens can help calm a hyperadrenal, a hyper thyroid state or a hyper pituitary state or a hyper estrogen state somewhat.
So adaptogens can be really nice that way, but the beauty of adaptogens goes even deeper.
So I have a prolonged amount of stress and my adrenals now are dysfunction, so I'm not getting the output of my adrenal hormones.
So I'm not dealing with stress very well at all because my adrenals are getting burned out. Adaptogens help build it up.
So that's the beauty of adaptogens. It keeps your hormones with an balanced range, call me the hyper output and boost it a high poll output.
So adaptogens are my first choice, whatever we deal with hormone issues, but it's mainly, it's mainly thyroid and adrenals with adaptogens, even though I've had numerous patients with obvious estrogen progesterone balances like hot flashes and such because they're going through their change of life that use adaptogens to help balance that.
So let's talk briefly about going through your change of life has a female. So what happens is a female when you get to a certain age, your ovaries, which are receiving the stimulus from the pituitary gland to secrete estrogen progesterone, the ovaries start to degenerate.
So they are not producing the estrogen and progesterone that they use to produce. That's your change of life and now you're not having a release of an egg and you're so you're not having your period, you're not getting proliferation of the uterine wall and you're not getting your period anymore.
Women could go through this change of life and have no symptoms whatsoever and are like, wow, I'm so happy enough to deal with my period anymore. Yay, life is better.
And then other women go through this change of life and they get all these crazy symptoms because they get their estrogen drops way down and then we'll spike way up again and drop way down and spike way up and that's when they get these hot flashes and symptoms like that.
And I have never had hot flashes, but my wife has and she's explained them to me after she threw a pan at me, no, she's, but she's explained them to me and they're not very pleasant.
I've had numerous patients with horrible hot flash issues and they're not very pleasant to observe so I understand that but that all has to do with this spike and drop of estrogen.
Because as the ovary shut down, something is not happening. So what happens in a person going through their change of life that really has no symptoms.
They stop having their period, they don't have any symptoms and they go, this is the greatest thing in the world. That person has very healthy adrenal glands.
So your adrenal glands for a female, your adrenal glands also make estrogen and progesterone.
They also make estrogen and progesterone in the male. So males have estrogen and progesterone as well. They're made in the adrenal glands in the female estrogen and progesterone are also made in the adrenal glands.
When a woman goes through change of life and has all sorts of symptoms, that is a telltale sign that their adredals are low.
Their adredals are low and they're not taking up the slack when the ovaries are starting to shut down and they're not producing the same estrogen progesterone and you're getting this spike and drop and the spike and drop.
The adredals should step in and help balance that out. But when a woman has all these change of life symptoms, it's because the adredals are not stepping in and doing their part.
Now, the adredals are never going to produce as much estrogen and progesterone as the ovary. So you're never going to have your period because of the adredals, you're never going to have uterine proliferation of the endometrium because of the adrenal output of estrogen progesterone.
But it should send you through your change of life without any symptoms. So when a person with a woman has a lot of change in life symptoms, it's because of low adredals.
So the first thing you would want to support are the adredals. So then you go back to adaptogens again.
So adaptogenic herbs can be really helpful through stressful things. They can be really helpful with anxiety because some anxiety is because of adrenal gland and thyroid gland fluctuations because of the two atary gland fluctuation.
And so adaptogens are my first go to other herbs that can be really helpful going through for ovaries issues for estrogen and progesterone issues are black.
So there's a lot of life issues and need some support for that. But I always try to use the adaptogens first. So, but the products like ester bite or there's a lot of other products in the market that have that are for female change of life issues that are really good products out there that I would use somebody asked the question on Facebook of a product, I don't know what name the company.
The company has a lot of really good products, but when the main component is a is a soy, we don't want to use that because that can can give us too much estrogen.
And though it could be really helpful for those symptoms, but it can, it could cause, especially with the first with cancer, it could, it could cause some problems. So we don't want to have that be our go to.
Now, there's other herbs, so we're talking about hormone balances with cancer, we cannot leave out this little piece, almost to decrease hormones in the case of hormone driven cancers. Now, understand there's 33 different derivatives of estrogen that are in a person's body at any given time.
And there are certain ones that are what we could call the quote unquote bad estrogen. So really quote unquote bad estergins aren't bad estergins. They are, they are.
Metamilite intermediates, meaning that a converts to be, converts to see, converts to D, and really we want D in our body, but when we have too much B that intermediate metabolite, that could be a problem. And that's really what the bad estergins are. They are a B
intermediate metabolite that can affect the estrogen receptors on certain cancers and not allow the cancer to go through the cancer cell to go through apoptosis.
So we have a number of different videos of that whole process itself. So we're not going to get into that again. But some of the things that you would want to do from a natural perspective to help that because you could take an aromatase inhibitor, which are medical drugs and different to box a bit and different medications that are out there that your oncologist would prescribe if you're estrogen or progesterone or too positive.
But women don't like to take those because of the side effects of them. The natural things that can help decrease these quote unquote bad estergins and help pull out too much progesterone are products like dim fermented soy. Now, don't confuse soy with fermented soy fermented soy products work 180 degrees differently than soy products.
products, which I don't think anybody should be eating any soy, whether you have cancer or not, can be estrogen disruptors because they're estrogen like products in soy and they can really disrupt estrogen eating soy can actually be a cause of cancer.
fermented soy tends to dislodge bad estergins from estrogen receptors so they can so fermented soy can be a good thing. Now there's never been fermented soy things on the market. Now, if you eat traditional Japanese food.
miso, not dough and some other things, those are fermented soy products. Of course, you have to develop a case for those and you have to have a source for those really fermented soy nutritional product that I personally know of, well, there's a couple, but the one that we use is the saddle gastro. So if you're on a saddle gastro, you're on a fermented soy product and it's meant to help dislodge bad estergins from estrogen receptor sites.
plant lignans certain plant lignans can be very beneficial to plant the lignans from hops can help decrease bad estergins and we have a product with that in there too.
So these are for good things to take and these can actually be good things to think and again, I'm not trying to sell products. I don't want people on too many products, but even if a person does not have cancer, these would be products that you could think of. And certainly if a person does our genetic test and they don't have cancer and they have a lot of bronca.
And some other defects in the tumor suppressor pathways that could ramp up risk of cancers, these would be products that would be recommended for them as well.
Hopefully that clears that up understanding that adaptogens are just classification of herbs that can help balance the thyroid pituitary ovaries, adrenal glands, they can be very beneficial for that other herbs specifically would be for help balance estrogen progesterone levels would be some of these and there's probably multiple more.
Other gladiators for the paedial gland, the paedial gland, the releases melatonin does make melatonin but it releases it to help you to go to sleep.
So using melatonin can be beneficial.
What hormone we're talking about, but usually when somebody's talking about adaptogens versus biomedical hormones, we're really talking about estrogen progesterone, the aderitos and the thyroid.
Okay, so we have an open up for questions in just a second, but somebody sent me a chat and said if I cancer seems to be stabilizing tumor markers going down, can you explain why I continue to get a sighties in the abdomen that am I right and left chest cavity, the doctors are puzzled.
Good question. So a sighties is fluid, so a sighties is fluid that's escaping from the cells.
So a sighties is technically inflammation, but usually we talk about inflammation, we're talking about a sore speed, some inflammatory source of like an immune reaction or an injury or something like that.
A sighties is typically inflammation or swelling from leaky cells. So the question is why does a person with cancer end up having leaky cell membranes and get fluid build up at all.
You could Google that you're not going to come up with any answers because currently it is not known why that happens. Now I have my theories that they're not based upon just my opinion, multiple people have these theories that that are cell membrane health is so vitally important.
That's why when you came to our clinic, we tested you for your phase angle and your total body water in your intracellular versus extracellular water because that's giving us some snapshot of the health of your cell membranes.
Now unfortunately, there's no way to test this health of the cell membranes in any particular spot in your body where we put those leads on your hand and on your feet.
That setting an impulse through your body and it's giving us a collective number. So that's not specific to the abdomen. If I got abdominal cancer or the chest if I have lung cancer, it's going through your whole body.
So unfortunately, there isn't a better way to do it at this point, but when we get that number back, that's what's called your phase angle.
So that's the charge of your cell membrane and remember what we said is that we watch your phase angle to be as high as possible because that tells us your cell membranes are as healthy as possible and it's a relative number.
And then we got back your intracellular versus extracellular water and in the perfect world, it would be a 60-40 split. 60% of your water is found inside the cell and 40% is found outside the cell or in the extra cellular space, the space between the cells.
So if that number creeps together, so now I'm at 55 to 45, well, that's telling me my cell membrane health is less healthy. And as we age, that is most likely going to be true unless you are just blessed with unbelievably healthy cell membranes.
But then you're probably not in our office with cancer. So cell membrane health is so, so important. And I've had numerous videos on cell membrane health because one could argue that really the braid of the cell is the membrane of the cell because it is chock full of receptors that the outside environment communicates to the inside of the cell through those receptors.
And it tells that cell how the function, and that's part of the problem with estrogen per just road receptor positive cancer, so it's we're talking about that bad estrogen attack attached to those specific receptors that are apoptonic receptors that don't allow the cell to go through normal apoptosis or through normal cell death.
And then the cell doesn't die and it can go through rapid replication. It could be a piece of the cause of cancer.
So as a cancer cell is multiplied, it's definitely not going to have as healthy of cell membranes as the other cells because it's multiplying quite rapidly and it's going to have the greater chance for it to leak its inside of the cell fluid to the extra cellular space.
Technically what a site is is a site is is an increase in fluid in the extra cellular space. So that that's that's it. So when there isn't any known scientific reason why that is the that is the major theory up to this point of why that is.
So why are cancer cells more likely to leak fluid because with the rapid replication there is not as healthy and they're going to cause more fluid language.
The other theories amount around if a person's doing chemotherapy that's damaging all their cell membranes and that can cause a site as well if you know there's there's numerous again just like what is the cause of the cancer there's there's numerous pieces to that cause what is the cause of any given condition right now which is cell membrane damage and cell membrane permeability is really what we're talking about.
There's numerous pieces to that too and that's where thinking of so if a person has a site is think of products like phosphatidolcoline so remember phosphatidolcoline which is our phospholide product or the phosphatidolcoline liquid bottle product that we have because that is the major component of your cell membrane.
So if you want to give the building blocks of cell membranes give phosphatidolcoline to the person that's going to be the biggest benefit so think of products like that that are going to help build the cell membrane.
Think of also you know lymphatic drainage, lymphatic exercises anything that you could do to help move fluid motion vibration anything times we've ever talked about lymphatic emotion and movement those are the kind of things that exercises that you want to do.
Also make sure you get your get drainage done so parents the thesis going in there with a needle and draw you that out or getting a port put it or a to put in a drain put in to get that drain can give you just enormous amount of relief and it can be temporary and you could get it out as you start to continue to improve.
Okay, I'm going to unmute I have time for maybe what are two questions.
Doctor just a little bit follow up that was my question this is Sharon and I mean would you be surprised if like it seemed like when the cancer started to advance I was.
Starting to get the aside these and I hadn't had it you know ever.
And except for one time I had I had gotten drained like the early this year when I was doing really horrible but as I was getting better I haven't had that happen and then it just started creeping and getting worse and now I seem to be turning it around and it seems to be stable and better does it make sense that I keep getting the fluid build up if.
Does that go hand in hand with cancer getting worse all the time or.
No it doesn't so I've had people become really stable and basically go into a full revision but still get fluid building still get fluid rating so that's not uncommon at all.
And just because the kids are slows down and replication doesn't mean there's still not a millions and millions and millions of very unhealthy cells with unhealthy cell membranes that are going to be leaking fluid.
Okay thank you.
Any other questions okay well we will wrap it up and i'll get this up on Facebook just as soon as possible.
I wish you all a very last day have a great day.
Thank you.
Bye bye though.
Bye.
Thank you.